hails of guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to episode 25 of network chat
programming so today we're gonna talk
all about disconnecting clients from the
server right so for whatever reason when
well I guess literally from a lot of
reasons but what happens is eventually
right
once the server connects to the client
you know talks there for a while
whatever the client is eventually gonna
have to disconnect right on because
first of all the server probably won't
be running forever but more often you
know the client has to just go to
somewhere I don't know maybe if I'm
talking to someone I want to end that
conversation I want to close that
program and I'm gonna move on with my
life or I'm just gonna shut down my
computer whatever for whatever reason we
need a way to disconnect a client from a
server and we need to kind of handle
that ourselves right so currently the
way that the way the connections even
work kind of is in here in server engine
just the server class here we have an
array of clients right we've got an
array list of server client objects
which represent clients that's why the
the array list is called clients now
this array list contains all of our
connected clients and we need a way to
remove clients from there and the reason
we even have to remove clients is
because this Center all method right
it's gonna send it to every client ok so
first of all the first reason really is
we don't want to be sending packets to
destinations that aren't accessible ok
that's just something that we don't need
to do that just waste bandwidth and it's
just it's useless ok the other reason of
course is that well we're kind of lying
to the server we're saying hang on I
think there's this many users connected
whereas there aren't ok and then of
course you know it might be we might add
the functionality to actually view how
many clients are connected or viewed the
client names and ID's of clients that
are connected to see who's online right
we might want to see who's online as
both the server and maybe the clients
even have that opportunity to see who is
online now if they do have that kind of
like guest opportunity to see that you
know obviously the server has to keep
track of users are actually connected
not users that have been connected
sometime
so um because of that you know we need
disconnect clients so today wouldn't
cover one of those I guess waste is to
disconnect clients and this is gonna be
when the user you know I guess we'll
call it organically closes the window ok
so if the user you know logs in
Cherno localhost everyone own to
whatever the service actually not
running but if we log in and then we
type for a bit and then we finally hit
the the close button or whatever we just
close it in that case right that's
called an I guess a standard kind of
close right that's where we close it
naturally we don't terminate the process
or we don't abruptly stop the
application we just look we actually let
the application close itself now in that
case we want to send a packet to the
server being like yeah I'm done remove
me from your server okay
so to do that when I first of all
actually bring up design here not on the
login page by the way that was stupid
and this was taken our a freaking pass
on this old MacBook Pro here but um if
we if we crack open our let's go back to
sort of this query that was the wrong
button there if we go to our client
window klass and oh great maybe not damn
it cuz it's not a it's not a window
builder object that's unfortunate isn't
it okay doesn't matter we're gonna have
to try this out by hand
I thought that it'd be easy to do it in
um and when they build it but
unfortunately this class doesn't have
window builder so I'm not I can't be
both converting into window build or
anyway so um I guess it'd probably be
better to type it out anyway so we've
got to create window method I believe
yup here it is and over here all we're
gonna do is we're gonna add a listener
for the close button right so whenever
the user presses this close button over
here let me just log in here and quickly
if whenever the user presses this close
button over here or if you're on Windows
of course it'll be over here if the user
presses that button we want to listen
for that and then we want to do
something based on if the user presses
that or not so we'll add over here after
maybe our button list not out after this
kind of stuff before the set visible
we'll just add a window listener so add
window listener and this will be a new
window adapter window adapter and then
we'll make it in our own in this method
obviously so in other words we'll just
we'll type out the method here because
the method that it has is window closing
okay well has a bunch of stuff but this
is one of it so window event a okay so
basically what will happen is if we
import on all this by hitting command
shift or or ctrl shift or if you're on
Windows basically anything we type here
such as system dot out dot print line
closed right if we just run this real
quick what you'll see is that whenever
we press that close button it will
actually be here so let's let's log in
here real quick
nothing special and then if I press the
close button you'll see in the console
it says closed
ok so in other words this any code
that's inside this window closing when
this window closing method that will run
if we close the window so ideally we
want to use it for sending a
disconnection back in now to do that
what I'll do is let's just first of all
bring it up here so string disconnect
it's gonna equal we'll make a quick kind
of prefix to it I'll just make it /d
slash because we've used C for
connection M for message and we'll use D
for the slashing stuff plus the ID our
ID which I believe is client dot get ID
yeah and then we'll finally need to
enclose an end a little thing to it ok
so an end
I guess not a prefix but a postfix and
then kind of postfix thing because of
course the but the the packet might be
more than well it will be less than um
essentially we don't want a huge
trailing whitespace okay now once we've
done that we can pretty much send it
right so the way that we'll do that is
well using our client let's send method
sews and and in the but actually hang on
I think we might have a different how do
we usually send messages because I think
there might be a bit of a bit of an
easier way so I'll let me just find our
stuff here okay there is a send method
so we'll just send we don't have to do
client I'll send will send and then I
think just a string and our message will
be the disconnect all right and then of
course we could do something along the
lines of quitting and this is what I
recommend you do as well if we go back
to our client or Java class here we
should probably make a method here for
actually quitting so we've got this
socket over here but we never actually
close it okay and that's obviously not a
good thing to do so if we're making new
method here called public void I'll just
call it closed okay
kurz close okay what I'll do is I'll
simply go ahead and type in socket close
okay and that'll just close the
connection because we really don't we
really don't want to keep it kind of
open after we finish with it and you
might just want to want to throw in a
quick synchronized half for the socket
into here so that it doesn't actually
terminate it while still in use okay
anyway we might talk about the
synchronized stuff in that in the future
but this will roughly just make sure
that it's not actually doing something
when it when it closes it okay which is
quite important we want to close the
difference still in use essentially so
having said if we go back to our client
window here apart from if we go if we
find our little window listener that we
just made here it is once we send the
disconnect packet let's actually just go
ahead and type in a client top close
okay or you could have named the method
quit whatever and I will essentially
just get rid of our get rid of our stuff
okay you can also go ahead and try and
join all the threads but honestly go
everything will resolve once you close
that window because the window is the
only thread with sorry it's the only
it's the only class with actual runnable
like wild foot while running loops okay
and of course the other thing that we
might do is just at running equal to
false all right not really necessary but
it's nice to clean stuff up like that
anyway that's it right this is what will
happen so essentially now what's
happening is our server is getting a
packet called that has a prefix slash
day slash so we obviously need to handle
that
if we go into seven main not so immense
or main to useless whoops
close that maybe not maybe it's not
useless it's only useful for actually
starting the server why is there a
goodness why is there a seven main class
my best song come on bruh okay so I'm
will use that result server of course as
we always do but in here in server when
we have our process here it is so what
we'll do is we'll say we'll make another
else if so else if our string here
starts with a slash date slash okay what
we'll do is we'll handle that okay so
how we actually going to disconnect a
I guess a client from the server well
first thing we need to do is really find
out what the server is so what we're
given right right now what we've given
is the ID if we go back to client here
you can see that well we what we
actually send this over here after the
after the in client window of course
after the fourth site default so that we
send the climate we send the ID of the
client okay and obviously the server
contains an array list of server clients
as their clients contain IDs you see how
this is kind of tying up cool so that
being said what warning what we want to
do here is first of all extract that
that ID from the packet so I'll call it
ID equals our string dot what is it
string lot split and then our rejects of
course we'll just be D and also if we
put the offing here also the end right
and we'll do that and we'll just select
the first index in that array so in
other words the second string in that
array alright cool so that's done now
let's write a method for actually
disconnecting so we'll make a private
oops
private void disconnect well as we'll
take in is probably just a just an ID
here and ID what else is that it I think
that's probably it
do we need anything else let me just
think real quick oh this is what we
should do right okay because this is
kind of this is kind of just future
proofing this because will also be
disconnecting by unnatural causes right
if the person's computer crashes or um
or I don't know they terminate the
application because it's not responding
whatever or or they lose and or they
they actually use lose their internet
connection that's another thing that
could happen alright your internet could
drop out in other words if there's an
unnatural course we might have a boolean
here that Connor is the status so the
status being if they disconnected you
know and by closing it some of the words
they disconnected or if they kind of
timed out right and timed out is
something that happens if essentially
the server tries to ping the client but
it can't get a response right and it
does that like five times or however
many times we'll set that and we'll set
that up in the
in the in the next few episodes you'll
same but we want to have a status to say
if it's I guess a good thing or not
right so first thing we want to do is
just connect client right regardless of
the size the status is just it's just
for us to print stuff to the service
console so that whoever's maintaining a
server can debug it a bit better so what
we'll do over here first of all is we'll
just go disconnect and then we'll have
to go I am integer dot pass int ID and
then the status here will be true right
which will mean I guess true true will
mean it it's by the clients kind of the
clients just closed it okay so it's a
kind of like a good status right true
and and we know that the clients close
it here because it gets a disconnection
string like that so the server doesn't
have to manually disconnect the client
the client tells us over disconnect me
so thus the client has a court has
requested it and thus is kind of like a
clean exit right and what we'll do over
here is we'll say we'll have to find the
client with the right idea here right ID
here so fire for sorry for in I equals
zero is less than all of our clients
here clients what size I plus plus and
what we would what we just want to check
out here is if our clients get I
oops dot get ID is actually equal to the
ID that we've provided up here right in
that case we want to actually clients
don't remove at the index of I okay and
the reason we're moving in index is
obviously that's the one that we've just
gotten here okay
so we've removed it now great that's it
done so um the other thing that we need
to do obviously is once we do hit that
one because there can only be one per ID
we should break as well just so it
doesn't keep looping through all the
clients if we were like 5,000 people
connected for some reason then arm we
definitely don't want to uh I don't know
kind of keep looping through if it's
like the first guy left we don't want we
don't want to loop through 4999 other
people if we've already removed it okay
that's why breaking is just a bit better
to do right now what we actually want to
do is I guess well we sort of want to
give feedback to the console so we'll
say string message equals nothing
now remember here will say if the status
if status is true so in otherwise if the
kind of user has done that will set
message equal to let's say a client plus
ID here well one thing we might get is
the name of the client how about that so
what we'll do as well is when we might
make a string here called name also that
equal to blank just for now and then
before we remove the client will also go
client so I'll get eye dots name
okay so we'll set name he called the
equal to that alright and we could
actually we could provide a lot of stuff
here couldn't we how about we do this
will make a client see which is the guy
who's kind of disconnecting will find it
and we'll set C equal to clients get I
all right
and oh sorry server client so server
client okay we'll set C equal to clients
get I and then over here we'll actually
well guys a client plus ID so we'll grab
the how about we do how about we do this
we'll grab the seedot seedot name right
plus and then we might put in brackets
the get ID right and then close the
bracket at plus let's see what else we
want so we probably want the the let's
say the address so I think we can just
go to a string and it'll and it'll work
not too sure but we'll say plus and then
the port number so we'll put a little
coal in there now we'll put the port
number which is C dot port okay so we've
got a nice comprehensive and then we'll
put a disconnected and a full storm okay
awesome
now if that if it wasn't natural we'll
just copy and paste this method message
here but we'll change the disconnected
to a time down okay
that's it that just tells the server
okay this is a specific this is the
exact visit a client that say the time
to out or disconnected okay and then
finally we'll just go system
line print line message okay and it's
nice and simple because of course the of
course the consult isn't sorry the
server doesn't have any kind of GUI it's
just got a con it's console base so we
can just use a simple print line to get
that in there okay and that's that's it
right that's how awesome this is
now there are a few issues with this
right this what this will work fine okay
but there is one glaring issue that I'm
gonna explain right now and I'm actually
gonna implement it in the next episode
okay but I just want to let you guys
know that this isn't all you should do
for a lot of reasons if we launch the
server main here
let me just get rid of them you know
what before we launch that let's let's
get rid of the we in in the wrong method
here we've got this system out print
line clients at sides which will use the
last episode to see how the clients were
added and stuff if we get rid of that go
back to 7 May and launch that beast as
well as launch a login window here we'll
make a yarn localhost a one-line to
login okay so here we go we've logged in
here you can see on the server let me
just bring this up a bit here now
there's an issue right we don't know we
know how identify here and we might for
some whatever reason we might know the
ID the ID of some other guy what we
could do right now and this is the issue
this is kind of like the security kind
of concern issue thing we could tie up
/d slash something like four six twenty
slash a slash but you can change this to
someone else's ID and it would
disconnect them right it would kick them
off the server and that's not a good
thing we want to kind of stop this
security issue because this is kind of
the code that we use now obviously we
wouldn't disclose this to our clients if
you were making a serious application
I'm obviously showing you guys because
this is I just realized I can make this
smaller
probably should have our care that
doesn't really work properly it doesn't
matter anyway so yeah obviously if we
were making a serious chat application
and I wasn't sharing the source code or
the actual um videos with you guys who
wouldn't nor did that was the the kind
of a thing you need to do right
you have to prefix it with his last day
slash you wouldn't know that and because
of that I guess like a trick you
- you know you know I I could
essentially just leave that security bug
in there and then you wouldn't actually
know that so it's very very infrequent
the someone will discover sometime this
however reading the source code or just
watching the video you'll see that that
is the case so that's why next episode
we want to talk about how to get rid of
this security bug will still use / day /
but we'll just implement something that
doesn't allow the user to enter
something like this and for the server
to think that it's real okay so great
get rid of that for now but essentially
what we need to do is actually I think
maybe it won't work it probably won't
actually I might have just explained a
lot but we'll check that out in a minute
but essentially what happens is if I
close this now what it'll say is nothing
at all great so that did not work at all
let's go back into our arm client here
client window make sure that uh this is
all working alright so we'll send a will
send this I think what will happen there
and the reason it didn't work is yeah ok
so this is the other thing that's really
important because this is the other
thing that kind of stops us from working
and this is what I was talking about the
security issue earlier a lot of people
were asking about it and there is
actually an inbuilt solution into it
which is great I didn't realize that
actually code it this way which is kind
of smart I have to say that's for sure
no but um if we launch this we
successfully going to the just so we say
stuff like that if we do say something
like /m slash right and we say something
after that and we will get a bit of an
issue right if we do say something like
/j slash it won't disconnect us so you
can see that actually works perfectly /t
/ avoir and the reason that all works
perfectly the only one that doesn't is a
/m but the reason that works perfectly
and that doesn't disconnect us is
because we prefix it with an M right so
what happens is all the way up here in
our server in our processes at this is
actually answering quite a big question
that you guys did bring up we see that
if the service starts with an M here
it's gonna send to all and if it's only
going to do the day after ok
that's why I'm gonna work so in other
words this catches up first and the
reason it is prefixed with an M is
because of a hearing over here in our
client window our send method which is
what we use you can see does it does the
four side and false - along with message
now sometimes we don't want to send a
message right so we can make a boolean
called oops a boolean called
whoops come on chana a boolean called
message okay and we'll say that um no
it's a bad thing
a boolean called maybe text I don't know
and we'll say if text then add that M
prefix otherwise don't okay so if we go
over here and to disconnect right we'll
put false but when we hit the send
button or we press the Enter key will
put true in it because that's actually
some text that the user sending sending
so this is the enter is the Enter key
will put true that okay
and that should now work right um there
is one more issue that we'll talk about
next episode but that's cool for now so
if we start this again when we join the
service successfully you can see here
we've got our own ID if we go back to
this we might you know type a bit you
can see it's working because this text
is coming from the server of course if
we hit the let me just bring this up
once more if we hit the escape the close
button here what's going to happen is
our prints it here that's weird okay so
it still thinks it's some kind of huh
okay let's go back a minute here all
right so let's go back to okay so it
didn't catch that that's what happened
because what happens is in server if it
if it's not sure what it is then it's
it's simply prints it now and that's
what happens so that was a bit weird
maybe you've got like a space or
something in the front not sure but um
let's just go ahead and I'm just kind of
examining this no it's fine
so it doesn't start with a name it
doesn't start with a day apparently
that's odd
let's try that one more time and we'll
see exactly what's going on there and it
shall be a good discovery I think
because these things usually are
because we've coated everything
correctly probably just not handle
something on whatever we close this okay
so it looks like I think there's an
excess space at the front which is kind
of weird let's go ahead and that's
probably it right there's two spaces
there think no no there's not
D so it's not picking that out for some
reason mm-hmm
maybe there's not a space in front of it
maybe it looks like it's just treating
it as text this is the server right yeah
so it looks like it's just trading it as
text which you shouldn't be doing
because I don't think we've got that
prefix anymore does it appear in no it
doesn't okay so it doesn't appear here
hmm all right so we disconnect and that
disconnect everything I believe so it
should be disconnecting this entire
thing here but that does not look like
it's working the pass ID isn't giving us
an error so this looks like it's not
true huh that's really weird let's go
back to client window and a little just
listening here as we send it with false
so that's okay message oh that's what
happens okay so what happens is we
actually prefix the word Cherno into it
okay
I should read that a bit more closely
what happens is we actually prefix the
message with China okay because that's
the name so what we want to do is we
want to move these text pretty much up
here and then put brackets around it so
what it does here is is instead of just
not doing this it doesn't do this entire
block of card because it's actually
prefix is it with a name and thus it
doesn't start with days starts with that
sure no thing okay which is in in the
first case in the world starting but
what sentence out was China was a bad
thing okay it's usually not now anyway
let's go back into server main launch
that login go to login and we can log in
here I'll go with yarn this time a
one-line to login we've logged in if we
come back here right back down here and
we've
the close button or we should see his
client yarn disconnected okay now what
doesn't happen is the application does
not terminate so that's one thing that
we need to add in in just a second here
but um you can see that what happens
here is it actually removes us from the
thing and it says client yarn with that
ID at this is the address of ourselves
disconnected okay wonderful all right so
let's suspect the reason that we're not
closing here is because it's trying to
do client I'll close but we've already
kind of stopped thread and we've hung
everything so I think what we'll
probably have to do is just put the
closing into a different thread so if we
just make a new thread here
and we'll come over here and go dot
start and then we'll just go whoops
public void run I'll just put my
brackets anywhere and then hit ctrl
shift F to format it for me what this
will do is we'll just create a new
thread and then do and then close the
socket so we won't rely on any other
thread and this should not hang our
application as it does in the previous
tests right so um I'll start a server
real quick I will start at clients real
quick and I'll just test it out really
quickly so churn and we'll go Y on
localhost a11 to login and then if we
hit the close button hopefully what will
happen is you can see that our
application closes and it says that we
disconnected it so the server knows
about this disconnection and I bet that
of course what will happen is we loop we
kind of removed our client from the list
and in fact just a test is really
quickly I'm going to come into server
and over here you know I not maybe not
gonna receive do we have any other kind
of while we got the managing loop
running here so what we'll do is we'll
go ahead and system to add up online
clients dot size will constantly be
printing out so let's terminate this
I'll start up a server and that's the
client start up the server again here
you see we're getting a bunch of zeros
because there's no clients connected so
watch what happens when I log in of
course here as yon localhost m81 hunter
hit login and that changes to one and
then
disconnect we go back down to a zero
okay so that works perfectly anyway
thanks for watching guys and I'll see
you guys next time
so hit the like button if you enjoyed
the video which probably did and I'll
see you guys next time come back
you